leviv is one of Eastern Europe's
architectural Jewels its Old Town a
UNESCO world heritage site
the church of Saint John the Baptist
dates back to the year 1250. the city is
close to the Polish border and has so
far escaped the worst of Russia's
Invasion despite ongoing airstrikes
against infrastructure but local
architect yulian jablinski notes that
one missile strike could change that
we're now standing in a passage that was
destroyed by a German bomb in 1939. last
year we saw Rockets hit keys in other
cities and I realized this war could
have serious consequences ukrainians
have been using sandbags to protect
monuments but that is only practical for
smaller structures and even then would
be useless against a direct hit
so chaplinsky started to raise funds so
that Annie levieve building or monument
that does get destroyed could be rebuilt
as precisely as possible
enter 3D scanning technology this team
is working on the Dominican Church in
levive
in total we now have 40 monuments
scanned using a laser scanner
photometric technology a drone and
photographs the results of the save
Ukrainian Heritage project look like
this digital models covering every nook
of History inside and out it complements
other initiatives like this one where
smartphone users can scan smaller
historic objects
it is difficult for me to say what is
most valuable everything is valuable in
leviv it was not for nothing that leviv
was included in the UNESCO world
heritage list the team wants to expand
its work Beyond Live But ultimately it
hopes none of these models will ever be
needed Redmond Shannon Global News
London